[Music]
welcome to year in review the show where
we break down a year to bring you some
of the most notable moments in TV and
film month by month while trying to
figure out what the best year in film
and TV was it's bound to start a heated
debate but one thing is certain 1999 can
hang with the best of them it was the
year of original Concepts genre defining
screenplays and yes even some box office
flops turned into cult classics
so from The Matrix to Fight Club to The
Sixth Sense let's take it back to the
year before Y2K
[Music]
forget how they would screenplay forget
those distractions huh
what do you think I have in that office
I think I'll work to do no Avenues
everything's gonna be all right from
here on in come on
look it's a beautiful day when The
Sopranos first debuted on January 10
1999 it was unlike anything anyone was
watching at the time for reference shows
like Everybody Loves Raymond friends and
er were at the top of the charts but
more importantly this show about an
Italian-American mobster from New Jersey
helped turn HBO into a premier
destination for great original
programming and change the way we
consume TV forever over the course of
its sixth season Run The Sopranos proved
to be a prime example of must-see
television relocate you and your family
you'll be completely safe all of you hey
don't talk to my wife so he wouldn't
have to go to jail either Camilla
Essence if I'm even indicted it's
assassination problem is not going to go
away I think both of you realize that I
told you to stop talking to my wife
Carmel why don't you wait outside kiss
my ass Tony we're the only option you
have left Tony it's not safe for you
anymore on the streets or in jail his
conversation is over what do you mean
it's not safe what do you know he
doesn't know anything it was a [ __ ]
carjacking now get out of here you're
upsetting my wife created by David chase
this sprawling Saga of a New Jersey
crime family was a perfectly balanced
mix of drama gangster Thrills and dark
comedy all anchored by career-defining
performances by Eddie Falco and the late
James Gandolfini critics say The
Sopranos smartly runs an emotional gamut
offering detailed character work and
riveting suspense while displaying a
flare for both comedy and drama
Family Guy Seth MacFarlane's pop culture
phenomenon Family Guy debuted post Super
Bowl 33 on January 31st 1999. after
going through two cancellations the
Griffin clan went from cult status to
Global sensation
[Music]
did you see the memo about this yeah
yeah yeah I have the memo right here I
just uh forgot but uh it's not shipping
out till tomorrow so there's no problem
yeah if you could just go ahead and make
sure you do that from now on that would
be great written and directed by Beavis
and Butthead and King of the Hill
Creator Mike Judge Office Space change
the way we view office culture and
adulthood forever the film follows the
monotonous routine of Peter Gibbons his
quirky friends his soul-crushing cubicle
job and eccentric co-workers at a
fictional software company called
initech
no not again why does it say paper jam
when there is no paper jam I swear to
God one of these days I I just kicked
this piece of [ __ ] out the window you
made both man
I think it's lucky I'm not armed
piece of [ __ ] but it wasn't exactly a
hit at the box office despite its
lovable cast comprised of Ron Livingston
Jennifer Aniston and David Herman in
fact the film only made a measly 10.8
million dollars during its theatrical
run milk we're gonna need to go ahead
and move you downstairs into storage BB
that could be some new people coming in
and we need all this space we can get
but there's no space so if you could
just go ahead and pack up your stuff and
move it down there but that would be
terrific okay
excuse me I believe you have my stapler
but thanks to Comedy Central Blockbuster
rentals and DVD sales the film quickly
gathered Steam and became a cult classic
that continues to speak to the hearts of
disgruntled nine to fivers all over the
globe
I hate this job I hate this job and I
don't need it the film is certified
fresh within 80 on the Tomato Meter and
an audience score of 93 critics say Mike
Judge Lampoons the office grind with an
inspired mix of sharp dialogue and witty
one-liners
10 Things I Hate About You And The
Matrix not that they hate about the
Matrix never mind do you want to know
what it is
March 31 1999 was a game-changing
weekend at the box office first Disney's
teen comedy 10 Things I Hate About You
hit theaters the film was a modern take
on Shakespeare's The Taming of the Shrew
and told the story of Two Sisters in
Seattle Kate and Bianca whose
overbearing doctor father forbid them
from dating in the fear that they'd come
home Knocked Up and to this day it's
still one of the most beloved and
quotable teen rom-coms ever released the
film also brought in an impressive 21
million dollars in its first five days
audiences and critics seem to agree on
this one giving an audience and Tomato
Meter score of 69 percent critics say
Julia Stiles and Heath Ledger add strong
performances to an unexpectedly clever
script elevating 10 things slightly
above typical teen fair and now for the
other film released on the same day that
has often been regarded for changing
Hollywood Forever The Matrix
unfortunately no one can be told what
the Matrix is
you have to see it for yourself
the future of movies basically began
with this action Blockbuster that was as
electric and invigorating as it was
visionary
[Music]
have you ever had a dream Neo that you
were so sure was real
if you were unable to wake from that
dream
in addition to being incredibly
Progressive for its time it's often
credited for pioneering bullet time a
visual effect where time and space are
warped to show parts of a shot that
would otherwise be invisible to the
naked eye
and while you may not think much now of
seeing bullets appearing to have stopped
in thin air it's made an undeniable
impact on the film and gaming industry
writer and directors Lily and Lana
Wachowski ushered in a new era of visual
effects filmmaking with their sci-fi
epic and launched a lucrative new
franchise for Warner Brothers critics
say thanks to the wachowski's
imaginative Vision The Matrix is a
smartly crafted combination of
spectacular action and groundbreaking
special effects decades later 10 Things
I Hate About You And The Matrix still
have passionate followings
[Music]
hold it where are you going to high
school because I'm a high school student
Drew Barrymore stars as Josie Geller a
25 year old copy editor whose first real
reporting assignment is to go back to
school to learn about kids these days I
knew it you are a loser you ruined
Never Been Kissed was also the first
film Barrymore launched as a producer
with her flower films company
[Music]
is the seat taken
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
are you scared critics say unoriginal
and unremarkable High School satire adds
a little to the genre
[Music]
I think this may be the Book of the Dead
The Book of the Dead
are you sure you want to be playing
around with this thing
no harm ever came from
reading a book
the Brennan fraser-led action adventure
film is a remake of the 1932 Universal
monster film of the same name starring
the classic monster man Boris Karloff
and although critics gave it mixed
reviews upon its theatrical release
Steven Summers The Mummy is looked back
on today with fondness the film spawned
two sequels and a spin-off franchise in
The Scorpion King
may also saw the return of Star Wars
with Star Wars Episode 1 The Phantom
Menace which was easily the biggest
cinematic event of the Year George
Lucas's return to the Skywalker Saga was
the highest grossing film of the Year
bringing in a whopping 1 billion dollars
worldwide which at the time was the
third highest grossing movie ever
released but with its reputation as a
franchise low point it's no wonder it's
rotten at a 52 percent on the Tomato
Meter critics say burdened by Exposition
and populated with stock characters The
Phantom Menace gets the Star Wars
prequels off to a bumpy albeit visually
dazzling start
foreign
I live just over the street I have um
water and soap you can get cleaned up
thank you I just need to get my car back
I also have a phone I'm confident that
in five minutes we can have you [ __ ] and
span and back on the street again in the
non-prostitute sense obviously when it
comes to Classic romance films from 1999
nothing comes close to the on-screen
Chemistry Between Hugh Grant and Julia
Roberts and Notting Hill written by
Richard Curtis of Four Weddings and a
funeral Fame Notting Hill was a simple
love story about a Hollywood star named
Anna Scott Who falls in love with a
small bookstore owner William Thacker
the film was a box office success making
364 million dollars worldwide and this
iconic line delivered by Julia Roberts
has gone down in pop culture history as
one of the most romantic lines in film
history don't forget
I'm also just a girl
standing in front of a boy
to love her
critics say a rom-com with the right
ingredients Notting Hill proves there's
nothing like a love story well told
especially when Hugh Grant and Julia
Roberts are your leads
[Music]
and I don't need any consistency in the
questions do I no no you're preaching to
the convergence
well if I'm preaching to the converter
then why are you being so slavery should
the three question form is my question
you're not even looking at me man now
you're just being rude you're not
listening man
[Music]
oh Behave funny man Mike Myers was back
at it again with his plans of world
domination the film centers around Dr
Evil's newly built time machine where he
travels back to 1969 to steal Austin's
Mojo
a shag less Austin Powers must now go
back in time to reclaim his jewels
alongside Vixen Felicity shagwell The
Usual Suspects Robert Wagner Seth Green
and Elizabeth Hurley returned for part
two with some fresh faces Heather Graham
Rob Lowe and the late Vern Troyer as the
iconic mini me man I'm gonna eat yeah
I'm bigger than you I'm higher than the
food chain get in my belly come on
foreign
critics say provides lots of laughs with
Myers of the helm as funny or funnier
than the original
[Music]
and one time at band camp we weren't
supposed to have pillow fights but we
had a pillow fight and it was so much
fun and this one time we all lost our
music and we were supposed to play this
song but we didn't know it so we just
made it up and we kept playing and
playing and the conductor didn't know
what we were doing and it was so funny
when Universal released American Pie on
July 9th it quickly became one of the
defining R-rated teen comedies of the
1990s its Breakout cast included the
likes of Jason Biggs Tara Reid Sean
William Scott Alison Hannigan Chris
Klein and Eugene Levy known for its
crude humor and that Infamous Pie scene
it went on to launch a successful new
franchise that includes three theatrical
sequels and four straight to video
sequels
you guys are pathetic I'm gonna find
myself a little hottie
critics say so embarrassing it's
believable American Pie succeeds in
bringing back the teen movie genre
so sorry
on July 14th three film students went
into the woods to make a documentary
about a terrifying local Legend only to
vanish and the shaky found footage made
for a massive Blockbuster that brought
the found footage horror genre into the
mainstream The Blair Witch Project was
arguably one of the buzziest films of
the Year between its January debut at
Sundance July theatrical release and the
internet running wild with the viral is
it real or is it fake conspiracy
theories
oh my God this is not the way to get out
of here
however one of the most impressive stats
about this film is the profit it made
principal photography costs a mere 35
000 but it went on to gross about
248.6 million at the box office an indie
film record at the time and it's still
considered to be one of the best movie
investments in history
I don't have it we have to go
I'm serious I don't have it are you
serious I'm serious I don't have the map
okay
but we can't talk about its success
without mentioning the way it reinvented
film marketing the film marketers used a
website to lay the groundwork for this
true story they kept adding new
information including everything from
pictures and footage to journal entries
and interviews with fake family members
to keep people coming back and spreading
the word critics say full of creepy
campfire scares mock DOC The Blair Witch
Project keeps audiences in the dark
about its titular villain proving once
more than imagination can be as scary as
anything on screen
foreign
[Music]
biggest box office hit to come out of
1999 was M Night shyamalan's The Sixth
Sense the Bruce Willis and Haley Joel
Osment Supernatural Thriller gave Cinema
one of its most classic twist endings
the movie became the rare genre film to
break through at the Oscars earning six
Oscar nominations including best picture
Best Director best supporting actress
for Tony Collette and best supporting
actor for a then 10 year old Osment
critics say M Night shyamalan's the
Sixth Sense is a twisty ghost story with
all the style of a classic Hollywood
picture but all the chills of a modern
horror flick
you want to see the most beautiful thing
I've ever filmed
[Music]
Sam mendez's American Beauty was the
critical darling of 1999 sweeping the
Oscars with five wins including best
picture and best director for Mendes
critics say flawlessly cast and brimming
with dark acid wit American Beauty is a
smart provocative high point of late 90s
mainstream Hollywood films
thank you
it's kind of like a bad French frill
Noir isn't it all these cops around in a
circle some silent
some leaning in with cynical Clips the
first season of the police drama series
Law and Order Special Victims Unit
premiered on NBC on September 20th 1999.
the show is a spin-off to the ever
popular police procedural and legal
drama Law and Order the series which has
spanned 21 seasons and has been renewed
through its 24th is one of the longest
running Prime Time series of all time
the show was also incredibly Progressive
for its time and has been credited for
changing the way sexual violence is
portrayed on screen
a man raped three women
he broke into their Apartments while
they slept and he forced himself on them
I'm just trying to bring him to Justice
so excuse me detective Olivia Benson
played by Mariska Hargitay has become a
pop culture icon for her fight in
serving Justice to the special victim
she works with who are generally female
survivors of sexual assault critics say
Special Victims Unit often blurs the
line between socially conscious and
exploitative but Mariska Hargitay and
Christopher Maloney's terse chemistry
adds a dimension of personality to the
absorbing Law and Order formula
the hardest job in the White House is
president
the second hardest job is not Chief of
Staff it's not National Security advisor
and it's not press secretary although
I'm gaining a certain amount of respect
for press secretaries
drama The West Wing premiered on NBC on
September 22nd the show depicted the
inner workings of the administration of
fictional U.S president Josiah Jed
Bartlett a Democrat from New Hampshire
who was played by Martin Sheen the Emmy
award-winning TV series ran for seven
seasons and won 26 Emmy Awards
talk about impressive
critics say The West Wing is a gripping
fantasy of lawmakers and government
operatives looking to make a difference
presenting an idealized vision of
politicking that audiences can strive
toward
[Music]
crazy you want me to hit you
that's right
what like in the face
surprise me
this is so stupid
[ __ ]
hit me in the ear well Jesus I'm sorry
but it was October 99 when we learned
the first rule of Fight Club the first
rule of Fight Club is
you do not talk about Fight Club but
apparently no one cared to follow it
because David Fincher's Fight Club was
one of the most talked about films of
the Year despite the fact that it fell
short at the box office the edgy
psychological Thriller was a box office
bomb opening with only 11 million
dollars and tapping out at 37 million
dollars at the U.S box office
despite those numbers the film has
gained cult status and is known as one
of the most iconic films for both David
Fincher and Brad Pitt stay with the
paint
of Heroes like the first monkey shot in
his face without pain without sacrifice
we would have nothing critics say solid
acting amazing Direction and elaborate
production design make Fight Club a wild
ride
[Music]
to infinity and beyond well not exactly
to Infinity but Toy Story 2 did climb to
the number 4 spot for highest grossing
films in 1999.
in the franchise's second feature are
dynamic duo Buzz and Woody Are Back In
Action this time buzz and his Motley
Crew set out on a rescue mission to
bring back Woody when a toy collector
steals him and plans to sell him to a
museum Tom Hanks and Tim Allen reprise
their roles as Woody and Buzz and Dazzle
Toy Story fans with witty banter and
heartfelt friendship with a 100 fresh
score on the Tomato Meter it's safe to
say that this is one of those sequels
that's just as good as the original
critics say the rare sequel that
arguably improves on its predecessor Toy
Story 2 uses inventive storytelling
gorgeous animation and a talented cast
to deliver another Rich movie going
experience for all ages
[Music]
Paul Thomas Anderson followed up the
Breakthrough success of Boogie Nights
with a far more ambitious directorial
effort in Magnolia the psychological
drama had a phenomenal ensemble cast
that included the likes of Julian Moore
Philip Seymour Hoffman John C Reilly and
Tom Cruise the film which was just over
three hours was an epic Mosaic of
interrelated Characters in Search of
Love forgiveness and meaning in the San
Fernando Valley
Magnolia found critical Acclaim and
landed Anderson his second Oscar
nomination for best original screenplay
critics say Magnolia is an ambitious
lengthy work that ultimately succeeds
due to interesting stories and excellent
Ensemble performances by no means are
these the only Unforgettable films
franchises and shows that came out of
1999 some other films we can't forget to
mention include Eyes Wide Shut Cruel
Intentions and The Talented Mr Ripley
plus several other noteworthy shows like
Freaks and Geeks premiered in this
banner year for entertainment so from
The Sopranos to Star Wars and The Blair
Witch Project it's no wonder that 1999
is often credited for being one of the
greatest years in cinema history